tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video sono fa vj e oggi siamo il nuovo
blog siccome sabato a prima spot per noi
che caso fa el to eye caldo ai così
caldo che ti dimentichi come ci si siede
ai culti tanto caldo che quando esce a
buttare l'immondizia torni che sembri un
ghiacciolo sudato non disperarti mio
giovane amico
esiste una soluzione da oggi acquista
anche tu favi ventilatore il fondi
ventilatore e dotato dell'ultima
tecnologia all'avanguardia per la
climatizzazione dell'area non sporca non
fa troppo rumore evoluzione a pile
tu sai dove vanno inserite avi
ventilatore dai un tocco di freschezza
all'attualità invia un sms che ho
scritto cristo che caldo al 33 36 c 6990
c'è vino a casa oggi stesso attenzioni
favi ventilatore potrebbe avere ferilli
svelati quanto ritmi aveva frutto e
punto non somministrare io mi dimetta
inferiore a quanto cinque anni
non fate domande vi prego prima di
cominciare ragazzi come ho sentito dire
partire con la finale della settimana
che questa settimana è stata vinta da
debbie che ha fatto allora la fratta e
bella cioè non è tra le migliori del
secolo ma è bella ma il fatto che io mi
sia unito ago getta per creare fa vi
getta è una cosa che mi ha fatto
letteralmente bagnare le mutande grazie
derby per questo disegno della madonna e
niente direi che possiamo passare alla
news la pena news lega e che allora la
poco iniziano alcuni videogames spero
che vi piacciano con una trama coni
contro maroni quindi non in dvd spero
che vi piaccia ragazzi e niente ve lo
dico in anticipo siccome il solito
parliamo di news legate soltanto al
canale passiamo a un qualcosa di serio e
sta cosa l'ha già messa ieri su facebook
ragazzi ma col cazzo che non la rimetto
perché è una tragedia porca [ __ ] addio
alla plastica da imballaggio con le
bolle che scoppiano l'azienda che la
produce sin dal 1961 ha deciso di
sostituirla con un prodotto più
conveniente
[Musica]
dobbiamo dire no a questo scempio e
dentro queste ragazzine che possiamo
passare agli eventi della settimana che
questa settimana sono un po strani nel
senso che ho provato giocare a golf sono
serio non sto scherzando
questo è stato il risultato
tailleur vabbè passa passa poi tanto
taglia era solo per vedere come si
spostava al 20 non puoi mascara credo
non possa passare ragazzi verrebbe tipo
da fare la roba in gp ha però non so se
posso fare comunque
potrei parli molto male mica sticazzi i
droni sono sempre più maleducati e devia
e la palla giusta se poltrone sono 2
mila punti a 2 mila euro mi sa che sia
sentito
e ho capito mi do all'ippica un gioco
sporco significa giocare svolto in poche
parole ragazzi ho provato a giocare
veramente difficile giocare se uno non
ha mai giocato una volta è un canone
come la wii
no proprio un caso se doveste che
possiamo passare al favini sponde di
oggi che bello regal fa vi risponde che
non è sabato sono risponde alle domande
vi risponde favi scocciati la faccia la
faccia cos'è una specie di perversione
team us tour vi guardando queste cose
devo farlo sul serio rigante già ho
fatto la ceretta l'altra volta per
cortesia almeno non da marga una domanda
sola veloce se vado ad abercrombie a
fare il provino così dite che mi
prendono lo so chiedo come cazzo lo
tolgo adesso sto schifo che a puzzare
per quanto il cazzo scocciato addio una
fermin attimo io non so come toglierlo
lega mamma ciao ciao
porca [ __ ] ha fatto malissimo nuova
ben scherzavo dai non volevo non volevo
fare posso tornare indietro e contro z
che in alto sexy io so minchia che male
assurdo non avete idea furo che avrei
preferito 300 volte la ceretta sta roba
poi risponde file raduno in i moli
molise
che cosa cazzo è il molise quali perché
fai tanti tagli nei video e allora
carmine maria e ad carmine l'avevo già
spiegato un caso di parità gli nei video
servono perché per togliere tutte le
parti noiose del video perché in realtà
quando registro registro tipo un'ora e
poi il video finale dura tipo 8 10
minuti ma errata o registrato tipo 1 ora
quindi noi che metto il video di un'ora
m video di otto dieci minuti con i tagli
questo serve un'italia perché sennò
sarebbe un video di un'ora ma una
rottura di [ __ ] che la metà basta
parma ma ross marostica marostica
marostica la perfezione indossa le
cuffie o grazie grazie grazie
cazzo cosa aiuto aiuto 40 ragazzi mentre
gli metteva a posto la roba per fare
questa scena o rimesse libri nella
libreria e ho visto un ragno
questa è stata la mia reazione
alessia piacentino farina come fai a
registrare con tutto questo botto di
caldo ma guarda in realtà è strana la
crisi perché quando regista perché
quando riferì praticamente rotto il
cazzo hai rotto il cazzo grazie molto
gentile no perché dolfini del blog meno
fammi finire che [ __ ]
si è quindi ragazzi detto essere che
possiamo concludere qui videla ma
comunque prima di finire devo farvi una
domanda assolutamente se potesse avere
anche voi un file ventilatore per cosa
lo usereste fatemi sapere con un
commento visto quindi ragazzi se il
video è piaciuto ma solito 18 momento mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e come
non i video tratta descrizione cioè se
volessi di scrittrici vediamo il
prossimo video per ragazzi